Let's go next to our caller from the 8 3 1
area code caller from 8 3 1.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Hi, this is Phil from California.
Hey, Phil, what's up?
They so recently, New York decided to spend
the primaries, and last couple weeks people
researching into the exit polls happened series
between Super Tuesday and some other states.
Do you have a lot of faith in the elections
these days and how confident are you in your
vote being applied accurately in November?
Oh, well, so there's two kind of the latter
question is an easy one.
I'm pretty confident my vote will be applied
accurately in November.
That's my belief based on what I observe voting
here in Massachusetts in prior elections.
But that's the more important question you're
asking is the first one, which is general
confidence in the election system.
I mean, listen, there's no doubt that there
is one party that has been working for 15
to 20 years to try to suppress the vote and
or to disenfranchise.
And this includes everything from redistricting
and gerrymandering up through and including
voter I.D., voter purges, et cetera.
Right now, it's him based on what's going
on right now.
My instinct is that 20/20, November 2020 is
not going to be as determined by maybe voting
machines as has been the focus in the past.
But how people are interacting with the voting
system in general, meaning vote in person
versus vote by mail and how corona virus is
going to affect turnout.
So because that is unprecedented and crazy
and we see one side Democrat saying we should
be voting by mail, you see Trump saying we
should not be voting by mail.
That is making me scared about what is going
to happen in November of 2028.
Now, all the other things like voter I.D.
that that those are all still issues.
But for me, what's most about present and
for most of foremost importance for November
is where are people going to vote?
How are people going to vote and how is that
all going to be carried out?
Because we know Trump knows vote by mail is
bad for him.
Yeah, true.
And I was also I had a lot of I have a lot
of Bernie friends that, you know, love the
earlier caller was talking about the never
Biden thing.
Yeah.
They've discussed it.
I think most people are going actually vote
for Biden because they are going to do the
math and talking to pollsters.
And April, for for the most vital are most.
I listen to a lot of it just real quick.
In 2016, I think you had about 10 percent
of Bernie supporters ended up voting for Hillary.
And that's why he ended up voting for Trump.
And they're voting for Trump.
10 percent of Bernie supporters voted for
Trump.
That's roughly in line with what we see in
terms of abandonment in prior elections.
Like there was not a crazy number of amount
of that in 2016.
Yeah, well, and Hillary's supporters voted
for McCain more than any supporters voted
for Trump.
Yeah, but I just think it's it's one of those
things where the Democratic Party had a real
chance to ignite a base and they may have
just created more independents and more people
that just don't feel like the party represents
them anymore, because frankly, the whole the
whole campaign just felt like a smear.
You know, everything on the media.
It was just so negative.
So I think a lot people just have a bad taste
in her mouth.
And voting for Biden is not going to help
him.
We will see where where it all shakes out.
I think that there's there's a there's a universe
where you are.
Correct.
But Biden still wins.
Right?
I mean, the number you could be right.
And Biden still could get the votes he needs
to become president.
We've got six months to go and a lot can happen
between now and then.
Yeah, we put a lot of pressure on Biden to
make our things happen if we're willing to,
so we should do it and try to deal with Trump.
Yeah, I agree with you.
I agree.
Thank you.
Appreciate the call.
Thank you so much